[Applaudissements]
et je dois dire que ça m'a pris par
surprise parce que les films que je fais
ont un peu tendance à être poil à
gratter et les discussions qui
commencent par l'ensemble de votre œuvre
ne peuvent évoquer des images d'hospices
qui sont tous parvenus à la même
conclusion lorsque des gens qui se
soucient profondément de la qualité de
l'art de littérature de photographie de
mode d'architecture de nourriture de vin
et de cinéma vous demande de venir faire
la fête vous y allez
je me tiens ici représentant le travail
acharné de milliers de personnes tout
cela pendant que moi j'étais assis à
côté à regarder la télévision donc je
dois maintenant les remercier
profondément pour cet honneur je salue
la culture du cinéma français le métier
la critique je salue votre engagement
pour un qui reflète ce que nous sommes
dans ce que nous avons de plus petit et
de plus simple et pas simplement nos
aspirations héroïques une fois que nous
avons enfilé nos collants
l'art de la peinture a des milliers
d'années le cinéma à peine plus de 100
ans nous commençons seulement à
effleurer son potentiel j'espère vous
revoir tous un jour dans son avenir
encore plus glorieux enfin je tiens à
remercier ma femme et ma fille qui sont
mon phares lorsque je suis perdu dans
les ronces les plus sombres de
l'auto-écrimination créative et que
seule leur crée leur gentillesse me
ramène à la maison merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]